البدايه معك اسماعيل ربما والوضع في
مستشفى
الشفاء صحيح تزداد الازمه تعمقا في مستشفى
الشفاء بعد استمرار حركه النزوح من
المناطق الشرقيه لى المناطق الغربيه لكن
الوضع الوضع الان اصبح اكثر من كارثه في
ظل عدم وجود مياه بالاضافه الى غذاء
وبالاضافه الى عدم وجود معدات طبيه صباح
اليوم استشهد ثلاث فلسطينيين متاثرين
بجراحهم ب عدم توفر الطاقم الطبي الكامل
بالاضافه الى عدم توفر المعدات الطبيه
اللازمه الان في هذه الاثناء طائرات
الاحتلال المروحيه تحلق و تضرب نيرانها في
سماء قطاع غزه بشكل ملحوظ حول الاحياء
السكنيه طبعا هذه الطائره هي طائره
الابات تضرب طلقاتها طلقاتها يعني عباره
عن جدا اذا اصاب اي انسان فيتسبب بقتله
بشكل مباشر وبشكل عنيف هذه الطائره تحلق
منذ صباح اليوم بشكل كبير جدا تقصف وتضرب
النيران بمختلف الاماكن بالاضافه الى
استمرار المواجهات
الضاريه الذي تخرج منه الادخنه بشكل ملحوظ
منذ
صباح قوات الاحتلال تواجه شراسه في
المقاومه انفجارات واطلاق نار كثيف في
المحور الشمالي الغربي لمدينه غزه بعد
محاوله تقدم قوات الاحتلال الى شارع
الجلاء من منطقه الشيخ رضوان علما ان
استمرار حركه النزوح من تلك المنطقه ايضا
وصلوا الى مستشفى الشفاء النازحين من تلك
المنطقه بعد دخول قوات الاحتلال الى محيط
بركه الشيخ رضوان وهذه المنطقه المكتظه
بالسكان والمليئه بالسكان لكن حتى هذه
اللحظه المشهد هو استمرار ال القذائف
المدفعيه في مختلف الاماكن منطقه الصبره
ومنطقه الساحه ومنطقه التفاح بالاضافه الى
قصف قوي جدا وعنيف جدا في منطقه الشجاعيه
ومحيط منطقه الشيخ رضوان هذا مجمل المشهد
حتى هذه اللحظات تقدم لقوات الاحتلال وجها
ومواجهات الضاريه مع المقاومه الفلسطينيه
في مختلف الاماكن